[Music]
hey guys
before we start this video i just wanted
to mention that only 16 percent of you
are subscribed
so if you enjoy the content please hit
the subscribe button to support the
channel
welcome to another installments of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing lord voldemort aka tom riddle
and what he would see in the mirror of
erised voldemort has a reputation for
being a representation of all that is
dark and evil
when you think of a powerful dark witch
or wizard he's likely the first one to
come to mind
and he doesn't seem to truly care for
anyone even those who are closest to him
not only is he evil but he's also
intelligent cunning
and manipulative often making others
believe that by doing his bidding
they are becoming closer to him perfect
examples of this are worm tale and
lucius who voldemort thought very little
of voldemort basically has
no conscience or sense of empathy some
would go as far as to say that he's
entirely incapable of feeling emotion
altogether the voldemort we see in the
books and films
is focused on one thing and that is
achieving power his own selfish dark
goals are the number one priority in his
life
but what we need to remember is that
voldemort wasn't always well
voldemort once upon a time he was just a
lost little boy
searching for answers in case you've
forgotten how the mirror of erised works
it's a magical mirror that shows us the
deepest most desperate desires of our
hearts
this is reflected in the mirror's name
no pun intended
as error said flipped around reads as
desire the mirror itself was made
sometime before the end of the 19th
century
and is located in the room of
requirement in hogwarts
engraved on the mirror are the words
which backwards reads as i show not your
face but your heart's desire
though it is speculated that the mirror
of erised was made for a bit of fun
it's worth noting that the mirror can be
exceedingly dangerous
as reflected in this quote by dumbledore
men have wasted way before it
not knowing if what they have seen is
real or even possible
the danger lies in people losing track
of reality after witnessing whatever it
is they've witnessed
in the mirror they've become obsessed
with what they've seen and are
completely unable to accept that for the
time being
it is just fantasy nothing more it's
natural for human beings to desire
things that are unattainable
and even more natural to desire things
period so almost everyone sees something
in the mirror
this leaves the question what would
voldemort see in the mirror
he's just such an important character in
the series so it's interesting this
information is never provided to us
in order to properly determine what
voldemort would see in the mirror of
erised
we need to dig into his past once upon a
time
voldemort was born to mara piquant mara
pigant
later mara p riddle was a pure blood
witch and the daughter of marvolo gaunt
merripe grew up in little hangleton and
developed an obsession with a muggle
that lived nearby
tom riddle senior who was a handsome and
wealthy muggle
merripe became obsessed with riddle and
using what little magical ability she
had
she was able to create a love potion
after successfully producing the love
potion she gave it to riddle
and he became infatuated with her just a
few months later they were married
and therapy was pregnant with tom's
child this child would later go on to
become
lord voldemort or tom riddle jr after
being married for a while
marapi eventually released tom riddle
from the influence of the love potion
merripe dropped the curse hoping that
tom had genuinely fallen in love with
her
but as soon as riddle was out of the
trance he went back to little hangleton
fleeing for merripe and their son after
he fleed
murapi fell into a deep depression and
on new year's eve in 1926
she went to an orphanage and gave birth
to her son tom marvola riddle
tom for the boy's father and marvolo for
merapee's father
murapi died shortly after riddle was
born after suffering for months from a
broken heart
marapi effectively chose to die as she
had no will to live
and because she wasn't there to give tom
love and care
he grew up without any concept or notion
of love
because voldemort was conceived under a
love potion and because his parents
didn't genuinely love each other
tom riddle was born with an inability to
feel love
for this reason he was doomed from the
start and this was probably the reason
that he went on to do the horrible
things
that he did but if things had gone just
a little bit differently for him in his
earlier years
could he have been a normal little boy
was that out of the question
to answer the question what would
voldemort see in the mirror of era sid
we need to first determine the point in
time at which she gazes into the mirror
as this will have considerable influence
on what it is that he actually sees
i think that as a full-fledged adult
during his most recent reign of power
voldemort would have seen himself
immortal dominating and controlling both
the wizarding and muggle worlds
he would have truly conquered death and
established himself as the most powerful
dark wizard
to have ever lived alongside him he
would have his legion of death eaters
all eager to do his bidding for just a
taste of power
as a young and promising student at
hogwarts tom riddle had
by this point in time decided on the
dark path that he was to follow
riddle was a very impressive student who
expressed an unparalleled ability to
learn
he was in pursuit of answers researching
practicing
and learning all about how he could
become more and more powerful
he was hell-bent on immortality and
attempted to uncover
more and more information about
horcruxes one of the darkest and most
evil forms of magic
horcruxes was something that tom didn't
know everything about
as information on them was hard to come
by horcruxes were instrumental in
voldemort's rise to power
and we know that riddle gets more
information on them after visiting
slughorn
but given that it's such a rare and dark
form of magic
it's unlikely that even he knew
everything about them
i think that after visiting slughorn
riddle would have still liked to have
known even more about them
i think that if riddle were to have
looked in the mirror of erised at this
time
he would have seen the restricted
section of the hogwarts library
and within it a book containing all of
the information you could ever need
about horcruxes
at this point in time a perhaps
uncertain voldemort
could have more confidently approached
the creation of horcruxes
which would have definitively determined
his eventual immortality
but as a young boy i think that he would
have seen something
completely different as a young boy i
think that tom riddle would have seen
family tom riddle powerful wizard child
though he might have been
was really just a sad boy made to
believe he had no place
in the world we all know every child's
greatest desire
is just to belong to know they come from
somewhere and have a place they can
always return home to
having grown up in an orphanage tom had
no sense of identity
he didn't know who he was what he was
and where he was supposed to go
tom knew that he was special but his
gifts at this point in time were still
unfocused
when tom first meets dumbledore in
wall's orphanage he says the following
i knew i was different he tom whispered
to his own quivering fingers
i knew i was special always i knew there
was something
tom's eventual diversion down the path
of evil
was all just a result of the sadness and
hopelessness that he felt in wolves
having been abandoned at such a young
age by those that were supposed to be
there for him
those that were supposed to love him
while at the orphanage
tom continually tried to convince
himself that he was special
that he meant something so i think that
if tom were to have looked in the mirror
in his youth
he would have seen himself tom riddle
senior and maripi gaunt
living together happily his father and
mother would have met by
conventional means and fallen in love
naturally
rather than via the entrapment of a love
potion
tom riddle would have been conceived
normally and he would have been born
with a better understanding
of love and emotion he may have even
seen his grandfather and uncle
but he would have envisaged them in a
much more respectable light
they would have been powerful wizards
and truly proud of their heritage
the descendants of salazar slytherin
himself
instead of filthy uneducated wizards
living in total squalor
they would all be in some normal setting
perhaps sitting around the table
of the family home like the weasleys do
sharing a meal
the table would be located in front of a
blazing fireplace
and the family would be cozied up on a
cold winter's evening
he would have an identity he would have
a family he would have a purpose
and his family would be truly proud of
him i think that if things had gone
differently for tom riddle
in his formative years we could have
seen a distinct change
in the wizarding world of course there
are some people who firmly believe
that because voldemort was conceived
under a love potion
he was truly incapable of ever
experiencing love that he was born with
a fundamental incapability of feeling it
or understanding it when we look at the
manhood that he became
this sort of makes sense however it's
also worth mentioning that our
experiences are what shape us
if tom had been shown affection and
shown what having a family is like
or known what it was like to have people
be proud of him
then i truly believe that it would have
superseded the effects of his conception
by the love potion because he never had
these things
tom riddle was sort of doomed from the
start he was destined for evil
and because no one was there for him he
had no escape
he had no other choice and for this
reason i actually take pity on voldemort
even after all of the horrible things
that he's done
and that's it for this video what do you
guys think what do
you think tom riddle or voldemort would
have seen
in the mirror of erised i hope you guys
enjoyed this video
let me know which character you want us
to do it for next
until next time you're a wizard